thank you
[Music]
and welcome back to a very special
careful boys we are very careful boys
and today we're talking about who is the
biggest impact on who you are today
that's a good question damn these type
of questions are crazy yeah the biggest
wouldn't it be your parents
who became I couldn't could necessarily
be that if you want I don't appreciate
Ryan laughing at him like that I think
it's a combination
I don't know if it would be like one
takes like the fool who's around that's
the biggest though what's the one you
have to keep yeah I like that who's the
Mount Rushmore who's about Rushmore oh I
like that too it's the Rush Limbaugh and
they got to be whites who's the oh okay
George Washington I have to be white Mr
Rogers oh Mr Rogers he was my favorite
white guy Mr Rogers man
Steve Urkel was my favorite one but he's
not white he's pretty white we just
yelled he's not white his name's Julia
white
man that's a good [__] question the
Full House dad Bob Saget
he was like a father if I had to do a
white Mount Rushmore you don't yeah oh
because the white I mean Mount Rushmore
is kind of white I've never changed the
prompt it's already white we can only
pick from one who are the greatest white
people on the on the earth
Bob Saget Jean-Claude Van Damme okay Mr
Rogers yeah and I think David Hasselhoff
David [__]
dude that's a sneaky pick pick the
Honeys that give me boners as a kid
that's tight that's tight
but his son was so annoying I remember
job or whatever his name was yeah oh the
kid that they will be on yeah
every week getting [__] almost killed
by sharks and [__] also you're just
envious very weak you're just envious
that he gets to hang out with them yeah
oh my God yeah yeah
I would say my my amount rushed more of
white guys would be the great whites
would be Hulk Hogan oh
Mr Belvedere okay all right all right
um Mr Bill Dean huh Mr building Mr
Belding you know that's a good one
that's a good one skins
yeah I like him what about the Charles
in Charge who's the boss guy remember
Charles on Charles in Charge Scott Baio
uh
okay and then the last would be
um Alan Greenspan all right Alan
Greenspan chairman of the FED former
chairman of the FED I don't know I just
made that word up I knew he was an old
special man
oh dude good list [__]
khabib number one come on dude
no four whites bro Stone Cold Steve
Austin oh that's a strong thing that's a
strong white man
[__] I think that's it dude that's a
stone Cold Stone I like how we all have
wrestlers
dude Stone Cold John Claude is up there
bro okay Jean-Claude
have you seen the splits ad yeah
I might have just skipped over a legend
who Okay Larry Bird no no Andre the
Giant but I don't know if he's white
because I saw him as a giant that's true
he's above Race he looks like a caveman
giant where is he from
I think he's out of Texas
he's from Austin
I have no idea what are you guys as real
Mount right now let's keep doing this
what the [__] Archie Andrews
you guys know what that is who's that
from Archie Comics oh
Archie oh yeah I think he's actually a
dishonest answer he really is a big
reason because Archie in the comics he's
he does every [__] job these are
great white Rushmore this is a real
Mount Rush well he's as he's the whitest
yeah the real one yeah no so it's not
even an uncle a a family it's just a
[__] person you never met before
Michael Michael J fox is one of them oh
wow that's true I like Michael J fox
it's a good pick so you're Mount
Rushmore and your great white mouse or
Mouse for the same thing oh you can only
pick one out of the four it's white it's
very strict yeah you know what
we got to change it did I lose your
Abraham
oh you only could choose one so who's my
my great emancipation who's your most
fascist
I'm really confused he suspended Mount
Rushmore has four yeah you gotta have
one
it was easier when it was four white
guys yeah because you could choose them
for different reasons I was doing a real
family oh okay well then
not your real person so wait explain the
Archer thing why why Archie for you I'm
very because I used to I grew up reading
him in the comics and in order to
maximize because he's in high school the
whole [__] time right but in order to
have like a million Archie comic stories
he you have to give them different jobs
and different lives and it just made me
think one dude was able to do all of his
Hobbies yeah and I was like wow that's
really cool my dad did like so many
different Hobbies but at like a certain
degree yeah like he plays in a band he
fixes his car he like he also is is not
too cool to take a normal ass job
working at a cafe like this guy's a
great great dude you're just explaining
me
yeah
yeah Joe sees himself and everything
truly Archie is JoJo right when Joe
stands in front of a painting
he takes the the colors and then he
paints Joe over it
yup yup he's like that's me up there
really like in real real life
damn that's a
that's a hard one yeah those are tough
can we do four can we pick at least four
absolutely not okay it has to be four
total or total thirty four you do
whatever the [__] you want you do seven
okay they just have meaning behind it
for me I think the first one I'm talking
about the number the first one is for
sure my mom
for both do's and don'ts
so the dues that I thought was really
dope of her is
um she got divor her my mama my dad got
divorced when I was six
and as a single mom I should never
really let me feel Financial stress or
anything like that and she always had
this very like I can solve anything
attitude so like when we got left the
house
um we had three other rooms so my me and
my mom would go to the grocery store
this is pre-craigslist pre whatever it
would go to like the Chinese grocery
store and put up like ads for like to
seek roommates and stuff so that my mom
was like no we'll find a way to like pay
for the house and keep the house we
don't have to sell the house or do
whatever so I felt like I got my spirit
of like there's always a way to solve a
problem through that and she's she's
like she's just tenacious like like
there's if she wants to do something
She'll always do it she doesn't
understand the word no she doesn't
understand the words or consent she just
goes yeah and then on the same side
where like my mom like loves to like uh
[__] contribute to Time Travelers I
think it made me very very skeptical of
like sneaky people and be able to like
kind of smell scams come in a mile away
so I think that really helped me
the other one is probably my
grandparents but those two would be just
like it'll be a two-headed head on a one
head on the Mount Rushmore
because I think even though I didn't
have parents that had like a loving
relationship I think they were my role
models of like how a relationship could
play out because they would I would
always see them as a kid like holding
hands like arm and arm walking through
the park and like just like look like at
like a really lovey-dovey family that I
was like oh [__] like couples actually
do this and you would just see how like
um
how Keen they are to each other's lives
like if my my Grandpa would be like oh
it's gonna be a girl Grandma's gonna
take a nap now and then she'll look at
his cigarette box and like make sure
it's like she's my grandma likes to
smoke cigarettes before she sleeps
sorry girl but like okay we gotta go
during lunch time we gotta go buy more
cigarettes
but they'll do like like little these
little things for each other you know
like uh like like lay out her toothbrush
and they would just like have these
little things for each other so that was
like my role model for love I would
probably say
it's not as much of a big influence now
but as a kid huge would be Bruce Lee
because I think like
um
like him being able to transcend all
cultures and him even putting maybe Hong
Kong Cinema on the map like he was just
such a cool guy that I was like man this
is like probably the first time where
all my friends come over come over that
weren't my culture watched a movie and
said my culture was cool cool yeah yeah
and I'm like wow that's really yeah
that's a big deal
and that was before like Panda Express
orange chicken
fourth one
how come you have to have four I'm
trying to well it's not much more who
said you made this thing I don't know
they said Mount Rushmore
The Prompt is who the [__] is the
biggest impact on who you became see
that's why I was like there was no route
Rushmore yeah Nick started I didn't say
Colleen said through Mount Rushmore and
then I just did a bit about it about
it's got to be white people she's
obsessed with whites dude look at her
she's obsessed with it
oh and then the fourth one if I had to
choose one is my junior high assistant
principal Mr Tarpley shout outs to you
um during the time where like I felt
like my life was over because I already
got kicked out like three elementary
schools
and um it felt like all the teachers
hated me because I always got sent to
the principal's office like almost every
single day and so much to the point
where the principal even believe in talk
[__] like you're not gonna last here for
long
um the assistant principal he would
bring me into his room
and uh he just made his room like a safe
place and he just made me feel like like
there is hope you know so when you feel
like the world is against you and you're
a [__] loser and you could only make
mistakes just by him like
um letting me be and not be ridiculed in
the front office and just being in his
room
um watching him like smear all his
papers because he's left-handed so I was
just sitting oh no sign [__] and just
literally smear everything
and I'm like
[Laughter]
there's always this glimmer of hope
where I'm like if this guy Believes In
Me Like I think I can do better that's
cool yeah so those are my four I love
that thank you Mark that's tight
and Mr Belvedere
you want to add him to the list no
number five no I like Mr Belvedere a lot
yeah he was really good he was a very
yeah we all cried Father Figure man in
your life was he yeah
maybe we all needed a bear
we didn't even know it's called bears
I was thinking about something else I
was like wait what like Steve's news
I think that's it that's 12 minutes
we're gonna end the video I'm really
trying to dig deeply and to see like who
really made positive impacts or negative
but shape there's plenty of those but I
feel like a lot of times when I back in
the day when I put like these figures as
my pedestal what I would do is like I'd
start climbing right to the point where
my crotch reaches their face and then
I'm like
slapping their face with it and then
above it and I'm looking down on them
yeah so then like I'm like thank you for
giving me a place to aim for but there
was a time
when I stop respecting you
has that ever happened to you guys
no I mean I'm Petty
so I I sense where you're going with
this because you're talking about your
petty well that you drive energy from
yeah yeah it's kind of like that but
then in a different place I don't know
how to explain it you have to conquer
your enemies it's like like let's say
there was a leader like a in your church
or a pastor or someone that you looked
up to and then you start to see that
they're human not someone on the
pedestal and then you surpass them in a
lot of ways and you're like
you're stupid and then used to think
they were so smart or they were so
powerful and I've I've had so many of
those instances happen very early that I
don't know if I um I had a huge distrust
in people or do you have skill sets or
character traits that you're derived
from them that you still rely on till
this day
I think there's positive and negative
right like kind of like how you have
like my mom is like I learned what not
to do and what to do yeah so like public
speaking or Charisma and things like
that I think I picked up from like a lot
of the extroverts in my family yeah
today's video is brought to you by Warby
Parker has this ever happened to you
you're like oh I'm online shopping and
these glasses they look so cool and it
comes home and you get it and you put it
on your life that's that's not what I
bought it looks nothing like what it
looked like in the pictures on the
website
well thank goodness for Warby Parker
because they found a solution for you to
be able to try on the glasses before you
commit to buying on it's called the try
on home kit it is pretty sick look at
this pair Warby Parker I got to try it
on make sure I was happy with this
decision before I committed with it so
the first way you go on their site you
select the ones that you want you can
choose from five and then it comes to
your house you could try on the ones in
front of a mirror be like I like this
this one uh makes my nose look big I
don't know and you keep trying different
ones until you go ah just like this is
the best one like Goldilocks says and
then the ones that you don't want you
send back the ones you want you keep so
Warby Parker offers you everything that
you need for happier eyes eyeglasses
sunglasses contact lenses and even eye
exams and you can shop with them online
or in the stores and glasses start at 95
including the prescription lenses try
Warby Parker's free home try on program
order five pairs of glasses to try on at
home like Joe said for free there's no
obligation to buy it ships free and also
includes a return shipping label try
five pairs of glasses at home for free
at warbyparker.com off the record and
then like um I would say like
maybe I probably have a thick skin
because of the negative [__] that I've
been through was like oh you can't top
what happened to me in my house so then
when it happens outside or whatever it's
like whatever so it's hard to Define I
don't know okay so to simplify it right
maybe there's teachers out there that
felt like they're like oh you're cool
there wasn't like and one was my Bible
teacher in junior high and he would take
like some of the students out fishing
and all that and he stopped doing it
because his wife was like Gabriel no no
I went to a this is the Christian school
I went to with Tim oh okay and back then
it was more I feel like there was more
Community you know like there wasn't
this like everyone's trying to molest
each other right so then like
um so there's no he was a he was a
teacher that was more like
yeah he was he was really
hands off it was different
he was cool right and he took some of my
um um buddies fish I was supposed to go
fishing but it landed on a Saturday so I
had to go to church yeah and then it was
like things like moments like that where
teachers kind of
it wasn't this like weird like
I'm just punishing you and you're in
trouble and then you'd follow rules
those were the opening things of oh
they're treating me human like they care
yeah hmm
yeah sure it's on a Saturday I know
right monsters yeah how about it Colleen
how about you yeah
um I would say my family my mom my dad
and my brother
um my dad specifically just because he
was such a curious person and he I was I
I took traits of curiosity and variety
driven in different like skill sets or
interests so like my dad was a chess
master he was like a professional rock
climber like where you climbed tie
yourself to the side of the mountain and
sleep keep climbing that's crazy he was
a professional dancer and like traveled
he was a he had like the first like
LaserDisc store too or like Michael
Jackson and Jay Leno came in oh wow he
like cut film like this dude just did so
much [__] like
um which I think just opened up my mind
to so many other things it made you
think okay well I don't have to just be
one thing or I have to try just one
thing
um so I think that was a big influence
on my life for sure
Nick Dunn you're up all right dude I got
I've been thinking about this
Rubik's cube in your head the whole time
so I'm gonna stall for the next four
minutes till this video's over I was
stalling uh but I would say Obviously my
mom and my dad right my mom
she taught me
how to be a little [__] stop being a
little [__] all the time dude that's
what she taught me no but she she stays
my mom is a hustler like she she gets
after stuff she's always staying busy
and she she knows how to be very um
very light-hearted and I think I get a
lot of my uh
my social skills from my mom a lot of
ways she's a really funny she's really
funny mom's hilarious and he's really
funny too he just no no no he's so funny
[Music]
you know like oh [__] like she's [__]
really funny she's she's way funnier
than I am because she says wild crazy
[__] and she just she doesn't she's
Unapologetic about it
um my dad I think I learned from my dad
how to be
um just watching him move through life
he's very adaptable as soon as he
[__] hit something he always finds a
way to make something happen right
um and I think that's a really important
skill set to to learn and to understand
that like okay yeah if you get into a
spot where say in a job you can't do
this anymore you could always pivot and
do something else and you'll be fine
like just keep moving as soon as you
stop you're dead in the water right
um
one later in my life was probably my Jiu
Jitsu Coach Joe the guy that is the
black belt at our gym
uh he's he taught so much to me
just based on being the most selfless
kind of coach teacher always thinking
about being just improving no matter
what and
he kind of he's one of those guys that
just leads by example doesn't really
talk much about like you know some
people they're they're kind of fake
about like the things that they do and
all that he was one of those dudes that
would just do things and we would watch
and observe and we would just be like
okay that's just the move that we're on
like he creates a Vibe of
self-improvement without even having to
talk about it all the time you know and
because we could see how he leads from
the front we all kind of take notice and
I think that's been so helpful for all
the guys that came up with him and
there's a reason why all these he has
like a
what's the word I'm looking for he has a
whole group of people that would do
anything for him just because of that
nice you know and his Brotherhood yeah
exactly like everyone will ride for this
dude he's real nice too yeah he's like
one of the most selfless dudes ever you
know and he's done so much for me
without even asking for anything back in
return he's he's just that kind of guy
and um I think later in my life I I can
it's helped me so much in the things
that I've done and how to just to move
forward so he's definitely one of those
guys that's up there and it's something
that I kind of really didn't think about
until these past couple weeks of like
damn this dude actually is a huge impact
on who I am today I think wow especially
later in my life yeah wow that's
beautiful dude thank you I can tell
you're like this close to crying
honestly no I love that guy he's really
nice he's the man how about you guys
oh look no more time dude well I'm
letting him are you good
but also too it's kind of hard to find
the words to describe all these things
because you don't you ask some good
[__] questions dude I don't really
think about it like because you're
probably right there's so many people
that influenced everyone here and then
like we probably don't give credit to
where it's due because it's just you
absorb these traits as a human and not
know where they came from yeah you don't
think about it no because you really
don't think about it yeah that's why and
you might even be wrong attributing
benefits to someone that didn't even
really deserve it right no yeah it's
true because I give my grandma hella
praise and my mom was like I did that
[__] and I'm like oh my bad that was you
I thought it was my grandma yeah oh my
bad yeah
um I wish I [__] knew what happened
to this guy but um it was my principal
when I was uh
I think when I was a junior
he was only principal for like a year or
two at San Gabriel Academy and then I
guess everybody hated him or like they
wanted him out because turns out he was
just like gonna write some book and
that's the only reason he wanted to be
principal was to like have the
experience so then like nobody liked
them but then this dude like I wasn't
even super close to him but I think he
like he did a good job observing all the
students in the school and he knew I was
like super [__] at school like I was
pretty bad and then uh at the end of the
year he was like hey I'll get you
excused from like first uh and second
period if you come do this thing and I
thought he was gonna uh ask me to like
do a favor or like do some work
and then it turned out he had me come to
this like like uh I guess there's like
something called a Bavarian Club where
they're like a community of like old
dudes that are kind of like an Elks
Lodge yeah yeah and then so uh sing
German songs or something sort of like a
Steiner scope yeah it's like a thing
like that and I guess he was a member
and he brought me to their like they
have like a pancake breakfast that they
do and they do it once a year where they
award one student
um like a small Grant and like a
certificate but only if the student uh
showed like high signs of creativity so
it had nothing to do with grades wow
that like nominated me for it and then I
I went there with my even no I guess he
just like saw the [__] that I do in
school I saw the hairstyles or something
and then he and then like uh so I go in
there and then he's like uh yeah just
tell them a little bit about yourself
and then like I you know told them what
I like to do whatever they're all like
clapping and then they gave me this
thing and that's like the first time I
got anything like that wow that wasn't
like directly correlated to like oh you
got an A or a b or a C or D you know
like and then um that fool is just
telling me like hey you know it's not
all about getting good grades right
and I was like what that's a mic drop
kind of yeah for a kid especially at
that time yeah principal too yeah and I
didn't know that he was going to be gone
I thought I was gonna see him next year
was he was he in the chair backwards
you know it's not all about the grades
and he told me like this yeah dude I'm
so relatable it was like it was how much
did he give you you're sick it was like
super not much but then the the main
thing was that uh his so his name is Dr
Penner and then um I remember that it
made me realize that like doing
something creative was worthwhile
because I've never been rewarded for it
like you like you get trophies for doing
like piano or whatever the [__] but like
in terms of what I thought was goofing
off he saw it as like hey keep doing
that because that could be a thing
someday and I was like no what how and
no one ever would ever tell you that
yeah so it's nobody no adult would tell
you that and he was literally the only
adult in four years of high school to
actually Target it like that out of the
game and then he pieced out I never saw
him again I don't know if he like passed
away by now or something and there's no
record of him ever existing he was an
angel he was a fever dream appeared in
the message
he's Michael Landon from Highwood Evans
that's sick yeah I was trying to look
him up right now but I can't even figure
out his first name I can't figure out Mr
Tarpley my sister principal I'm trying
to look look him up for years but it's
just it was during that time predates
the uh the public storage of data yeah
they made such an impact on you guys you
forgot their [__] names I know mine
this is Marlon
yeah but yeah it's it's crazy to think
that that that does change everything
even though it was like that one gesture
because really I thought all the
creative stuff I liked doing was a
distraction from what I'm supposed to be
doing so it's like oh like you shouldn't
be doing that until this is done but
then here I was like oh there's a good
side to it yeah
yeah what about you quickly right in and
out Bill Murray for sure because I
remember watching Ghostbusters a little
kid and going like that's what I want to
do and be funny person and then that was
awesome for me but then like
um my grandfather definitely for showing
me my father and my grandfather for
showing me like what's what it's about
like being a man what it's about and
like how important it is to like you
can't just like be a like um you know a
forceful person like my grandfather I
always thought I was like this forceful
person and [__] he's a veteran veteran
Marine badass [__]
when he got taken to the hospital at the
end of his life he had just gone to
Costco like two days prior and they're
like this guy has like four broken ribs
and he he wasn't even in the hospital
for that like he was just on another
level never ever let them see you bleed
was this whole thing like you just don't
like bleed on people like you just you
know you're you're a strong person as
[__] but then that's another beautiful
thing I learned from him because he
would always shut himself in I think he
was dealing with a lot of pain obviously
physical pain not that I know that but
he would he would like watch movies on
full blast in the other room he's like
watching old war movies and [__] like
[__] like like Bunker Hill and just
[__] that nobody wants to sit there and
watch right the river Bears over the
river dude [__] all this terrible
[__] and then um and so I but I think
that you know watching him do that I was
like I don't want to be that guy like I
don't want to be the guy where everyone
is like my family's around and I am
absconded it's like alienated yeah yeah
and and who knows what he was doing with
I try not to judge obviously but it's
like man I really did learn like like so
much strength from him but then I saw so
much weakness in that and I tried to do
the opposite of that tried to be
empathetic try to understand where
people are coming from a lot more
um and then obviously I think that um
I think that Hitler
for what not to do
thank God for that last
[Music]